so meanwhile joe biden's handling of the
pandemic has been disastrous mainly
because they just refused to acknowledge
the reality which is that the pandemic
for the vast majority of people is over
and when i say it is over i don't mean
that omicron isn't killing people it is
killing some people i'm not saying that
omicron isn't hitting people it's
hitting nearly everybody what i mean is
that how you choose to react to omicron
is up to you and it is up to your local
politicians and your state politicians
and your federal politicians so barry
weiss of uh of former new york times
fame and sub stack fame barry weiss was
on bill maher's show over the weekend
and barry made the perfectly obvious
point that she hangs out with liberals
all day which she does she lives in a
very blue area barry is is not
conservative she is in anti-radical left
liberal sort of andrew sullivan mode uh
sort of in the mode of some of the
members of the intellectual dark web and
barry weiss
she came out and she said this pandemic
policy will be remembered as a
catastrophic moral failure
you will realize most importantly that
this is going to be remembered by the
younger generation as a catastrophic
moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80
percent i think minority students has
just announced indefinite virtual
schooling in the past two years we've
seen among young girls a 51 increase in
self-harm people are killing themselves
they are anxious they are depressed they
are lonely
that is why we need to end it more than
any inconvenience that it's been to the
rest of us
okay she's right about this now
hilariously there are some people on the
right were very critical of barry
because the outpouring was very pro
berry online
okay here's the thing guys take your
allies where you can get them it doesn't
mean that folks who have been
center-left on this issue have been
right the whole pandemic they have not
been people who were left at the
beginning of the pandemic and were
suggesting that we needed to lock down
interminably and then particularly
people who were left after the vaccines
were available who've been following the
vouchers of the world got it wrong the
enti nearly the entire time they got it
wrong okay but
now that the worm is turning don't start
saying that it's bad for people to join
the club it is good for people to join
the club of course this policy has been
massively destructive and must never be
allowed to happen again but here is the
thing the public health bureaucracy will
not allow it to stop they won't allow it
to stop now down here in florida things
have been normal for what a year a year
and a half like people have been acting
like normal for a year and a half
particularly if you're young and healthy
people have just been going out and
living their lives
for if you were 20 years old and healthy
in florida the pandemic lasted for about
three weeks
in terms of your personal behavior right
the first three weeks you were freaked
out and then you realized was hitting a
bunch of old people and you were like
okay if i don't hang out with old people
and i hang out with my friends i'm fine
okay that was the mentality in florida
and then once the vaccines were
available the mentality was i'm done we
are finished i remember last passover
there was
basically a fairly open unmasked party
you know now that was like march of last
year because the vaccines were now
widely available to everyone and
everyone felt safe because they should
feel safe because the vaccines were
effective in preventing hospitalization
and death we are now like almost a year
past that almost a year past that
and still the left will not let go only
in blue areas now i'm just amazed by
this i told you last week about paul
krugman column in the new york times in
which he was talking about how you know
it's because of red state failures to
abide by our strictures that omicron
continues and it's like dude what's
slowing down the country is you what is
slowing down the country is coveted
paranoia according to the wall street
journal quote schools may be open but
they're struggling but here's the thing
i kind of noticed that this is relegated
mostly to blue areas
here's what they say schools should be
open pandemic or not much of the public
says if only they all had what they need
to function students at new york city's
elite brooklyn technical high school
played hangman in psychology class
recently while a substitute sat behind
the teacher's desk
they were eager to prepare for a coming
midterm exam but their usual instructor
was out sick again
everyone's kind of freaking out said
delia marcus 17 we haven't really
learned anything the fast spreading
omicron variant of coven 19 has dealt a
fresh pandemic blow to brooklyn tech one
of the nation's largest high schools
with more than 5 800 students and among
the most competitive with an admission
rate under 10 percent the problem there
and in many other schools boils down to
a mismatch between demand and supply
while many officials and parents
nationwide push to keep kids in schools
and away from remote learning omicron
has left many schools short of the
essentials needed to operate like
teachers substitutes bus drivers
cafeteria workers and sometimes students
themselves
teachers say they struggle to teach in
classrooms while also delivering remote
lessons to students who can't attend
because they tested positive or were
near someone who did and yet the left
can't let it go they just cannot so
kathy hokel up in new york she's still
defending mass mandates for kids based
on nothing based on zero things it's
crazy here she is
i know people are tired but i also say
one thing about the kids
my daughter had a meltdown over having
to put sneakers on to go to kindergarten
she got used to wearing sneakers in
school they just
they adapt better than adults do and
i'm really proud of the parents who made
sure that their kids understood this is
for their safety and got it done
okay this is insane i'm sorry kids do
not adjust better than adults do to
things like wearing masks
and if they do is because they have now
imbibed the insanity from their parents
and their grandparents i don't know what
kind of society sacrifices the future
and the current welfare of their
children on behalf of the 80 year olds i
don't know what kind of society does
that to prevent to pretend that it is
the kids who are the danger to a society
where everyone is now having omicron
unmask and the kids are the least
vulnerable is totally crazy
but again the public health bureaucracy
can't let go because to let go would be
to acknowledge that they got it wrong in
the first place do you still have
anthony fauci out there i don't know why
he's still out there he's still saying
don't get overconfident why is anyone
listening to this dunderhead why he's
been wrong every step of this pandemic
it's amazing
ultimately they're all going to go in
the same direction there may be
a bit more pain and suffering with
hospitalizations
in those areas of the country that have
not been fully vaccinated or have not
gotten boosters but we do know and that
these are the recent data that have come
out from the cdc
that even with omicron boosting makes a
major major difference in protecting you
from hospitalization and severe outcomes
so things are looking good we don't want
to get over confident but they'll look
like they're going in the right
direction right now
we don't want to get overconfident we
never want to get overconfident we can't
get overconfident i mean like what in
the hell what in the hell you couldn't
control this thing the entire time i
can't get overconfident meanwhile biden
cdc director is still telling people
that fully vaccinated now means boosted
that's what it means just endless by the
way you know what the number one country
on planet earth right now in terms of
per capita omicron cases is israel where
everyone is like boosted eight times
in israel 80 of your body weight is now
the vaccine here's joe biden's cdc
director trying to say that fully
vaccinated is now boosted it doesn't
matter if you like me had two doses plus
omicrons i now have natural immunity
none of that matters
by the way i think i had omicron i
didn't test positive for it to be fair
although some of my family did anyway
here we go
right now we're pivoting our language we
really want to make sure people are up
to date that means if you recently got
your second dose you're not eligible for
a booster you're up to date if you are
eligible for a booster and you haven't
gotten it you're not up to date and you
need to get your booster in order to be
up to date
they're just crazy they're just crazy
meanwhile they're doing nothing by the
way to actually get the coveted pills
that people need in place right the
therapeutic how is it that we've known
for several months at this point that
there are therapeutics available that
lower the rate of hospitalization death
by like 90 to 100
this would be pfizer's pax levitt
why why is it that that has has we still
like 200 000 doses available for a
country and three of 330 million like
this is nuts
again the failures on the governmental
level are astonishing and continuing but
we are supposed to believe them even
though everyone has basically gone back
to normal in their daily lives in the
same areas of the country so get the
left should they get as pissed at barry
weiss and bill maher as they want but
the reality is that barry and bill have
it right because we had it right before
barry and built it
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang